hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm James Franco
I'm Rachel
welcome to hurt isn't the sea where we
give you reasons to see and not to see
Oz the great and powerful
so let's hang out after being thrust
into the magical world of Oz conman and
carnival magician Oscar Diggs has to
help the people of Oz fulfill the
prophecy and vanquish the Wicked Witch
and in the process you know become not
an [ __ ] and become The Wonderful
Wizard of Oz ryan's consensus there are
some reasons to see oz the great and the
powerful there are some reasons to see
Oz the great and the powerful yeah it's
not a great film it's it's not a bad
film it's a it's a decent family movie
James Franco's consensus yeah I think
there are a lot of reasons to see how is
the green powerful there are a lot of
reasons to see oz the great and powerful
yeah I mean I get all the complaints but
for me you know I got lost in the magic
and I had a really great time so you
know while it's not a perfect film I
really enjoyed rachel's consensus there
are a few reasons to see oz the great
and powerful there are a few reasons to
see oz the great and powerful overall
it's kind of silly but you know it's
good enough for the whole family to see
together so I think that that makes it
okay reason to see number one James
Franco I like James Franco you know he
always gets me even if he's just doing
an okay job because I thought I did an
okay job with this film but he's really
fun to watch he had a lot of moments
where he actually had me cracking up and
so I really enjoyed him a lot in this
movie you know James Franco is an actor
who it's hard to kind of lose him in a
role and actually here especially in a
period piece I eventually did buy him so
I enjoyed watching him he is the biggest
smile
I have ya ever seen like that is one
scene as me learning yeah
big well I thought that he pulled off
the the whole conman thing pretty well
you kinda have to wonder you know was he
a con man at some point in his life he
seemed to really just be having a very
fun time while he was on set and just
really seem to you know being enjoying
himself yeah I actually I liked him I
thought he was really slimy but it was a
good slimy that worked with the movie so
you seem to really like his con artist
um yeah yeah absolutely I thought you
know it was good but you know he you
know progressed but dead like the slim
well the thing is - I thought he was
very natural with the balance between
being a jerk
and being you know caring and sort of
learning his lessons throughout this
movie because he's not he's he's good at
being a jerk but he's not so much of a
jerk that by the end you're like why you
know yeah he's a dick but he's a
charming dick yeah and you do see him
care genuinely for certain characters
during certain situations where I
believe the transition coming from his
sympathetic to his plight yeah
definitely yeah because you know it's
like he thinks he's not a good guy but
everyone can see he's really good on the
inside yeah and you know but it's
charming though it's likeable reason to
see number two double monkey this monkey
was probably my favorite thing about the
film even more than James Franco Zach
Braff yeah I love scrubs I've been
wondering where the guy's been since
Garden State and it's cool to see him
return as a monkey he was in human form
for a couple minutes and you know he's
he's really good at both roles I know
one thing I want to say about the monkey
is that usually with animated sort of
CGI characters in order to make
something really you know expressive and
emotive they make their eyes about the
size of half their face yeah you know
like I mean you take a you know golem or
puss-in-boots from Shrek you know
they've got these very exaggerated eyes
but with the monkey I mean it's it's a
normal like all the proportions are
exactly the way a monkey looks but
somehow I just you know they don't
really need a like cheat I guess with
you know exaggerating anything any
features because the monkey is adorable
yeah
just works anyway that is the keyword
for the monkey in the film it's he's
just adore ya you wish it was real so
you can hang out with it and you know so
you know which like James Franco and the
monkey have like great chemistry the way
they play off each other was very fun to
watch reasons to see number three three
ball effects you guys like visual
effects
I like visual effects there's so this
movie you know it's weird because we
need one can't help but compare it to
the Wizard of Oz at times because The
Wizard of Oz was not hell-bent on visual
effects this film is like mainly visual
effects I think they were very much
about visual effects but you know I'm
talking in terms of CGI well I couldn't
invent it yet but that's what made
Wizard of Oz such a delight to watch was
yeah like the fact of how at that time
period they managed to build such a
grand production design for a film that
you know didn't have gonna provide stuff
like CGI and I can see why having so
much CGI everywhere in so much little
detail and stuff like that can make the
experience kind of hollow for me though
especially the way the movie juxtaposes
the beginning which is which is in black
and white and it said in the real world
with us I did get lost in the wonder of
what they created for the world so I
liked the visual effects for the most
part I thought they did a good job there
did you get lost in it the Wonder as I
didn't get lost in the Wonder I admired
the visual effects but I didn't pull me
in enough to get me lost in the Wonder I
think you know but I'm 22 and so by the
time oh my gosh I can't you know and I
think just like considering the
environment I personally grew up in
where you know my dad does a lot of this
stuff I can't I can't really be involved
in that you know dad did the opening
credits for this movie that's true
a bunch bunch of other people including
my day I want to be like my dad's the
only [ __ ] guy who but you know but
it's my dad was definitely one of the
main people who did it but I can
definitely like see that it's beautiful
yeah that's what I mean you know they
obviously put a lot of time and effort
and it'll work you know for people so
I'm like yeah totally so you know this
is pretty that's what I mean it's
admirable but it doesn't like and gross
me in the world reason to see number
four
cinematography yeah like we were saying
about the visual effects it just looks
everything looks really good and the
lining of it especially the the framing
of it you know it was cool how they
started off with the black and white and
four by three yeah and then it goes and
just like how they did with the original
that when it goes into color and you
watch it extend its coma see that in the
theaters - do you guys see the 3d no I
want I you know this is every time I
choose not to go to a 3d movie it's
always the one I should have gone to cuz
watching the movie I was like this
probably looks pretty cool in 3d and
everyone I've heard has been like the
3ds yeah so as I saw it in 3d and I got
to tell you like especially since we're
talking about the cinematography the 3d
is surprisingly really good like there
were some moments where you're like that
is really coming at me right now well
it's kind of cool of how it's like black
and white in the beginning because
similar to the Wizard of Oz when it was
black and white at the beginning you
know she would she wants more and then
she gets to us and it's a Land of Oz and
then you know that's when it becomes her
life is full of color and same thing
with this guy you know I liked how they
did that with Oz how it's a similar
situation his life is sort of black and
white at this moment and then you know
when he gets put in the line of Oz
that's when his life becomes a whole
color of palette I really like the
little Sam Raimi touches like that you
know when when when creepy things start
to happen like that like drastic the
booms and the Dutch angles and like
chaos you know I really enjoyed yeah
whenever there was the rainy flare that
would that's when I thought the film is
at its best yeah reason to see number
five the score I always liked Danny
Elfman scores yes I score he has a good
track record
yeah I liked his score and it's cool
here because it's it's danny elfman
without being like danny elfman you know
like because some of specially some of
the more burton ii things are like oh
like you don't like me really Danny I'll
finish and this one is its signature but
it's a little more out there and there's
a lot of cool carnival instruments use
it it blends into the world better then
stands out as like loud Danny often
music which often happens in Tim Burton
movies yeah because it's so in your like
player yeah but the music blends really
well into this world yeah yeah cuz it's
not it's not Danny Elfman like super
crate [ __ ] yeah it's like it's it's
it fits like the realm of it's not like
like I I like Danny Elfman okay but like
sometimes he just gets like you know but
I thought that in in this movie it fit
with the rest I felt like someone gave
him some guidance yeah do the music in
this one yeah yeah exactly
alright so let's move on to the split
decisions now did not like Mila Kunis
and this won't be like ooh this did not
like me like yes yeah no all right I'm a
little Jerry can't can't be in our club
I thought she was very bland you know
that's probably in terms of the writing
but didn't really see the chemistry
between her and james franco mila kunis
is a good actress I thought she gave a
very half-assed job in this film I
thought she committed I mean it's she
her performance makes sense to me
because it is in a sort of a PG realm
like in a more family environment but
because she's a little bit wide-eyed in
a little like oh you know mystical but I
like what she didn't I thought she
committed to it she didn't wood board to
me or anything I was bored of her
performance and I didn't care about her
character at all I did care about her
character the I will say they could have
given her more conflict and more depth
at certain points especially later on in
the movie but I thought she did a fine
job yeah
I'm a little bit with it well I think
that in the beginning it was what kind
of really awkward to watch them together
and I was a little bit like oh boy
freaking psycho you know you know but I
thought that like in that aspect I think
I was supposed to be kind of awkward so
I was like okay yeah this is this is
supposed to be a little weird to stomach
but then you know when you realize that
she's the witch I just you know I just
couldn't I couldn't buy that she was
going you know she was just too like she
just wasn't a witch to me you know she
was just you know pretty and yes very
believable as the person they first
introduced her as and they established
right away that she's a witch and then
when you explore her which aspects it's
not believable to me there are scenes
where she's required to be emotional and
it just seemed like a whiny teenager she
just doesn't she's not like really a
witchy sort of character is the thing
but I just don't think she's yeah
there's nothing that's that's true but
like you're you know she's supposed to
become the witch and I don't think she
ever like really yeah a hint that dark
sides within her and you don't really
feel that yeah you just kind of feel
like she was I feel like she has a
little bit of a whiny girl temper but
not the darkness of a hint add in her
what decision number two Rachel Weisz I
can't really talk too much about why I
didn't like her performance because I
don't want to give too much away but I
felt like the direction on her was I
can't give it away but it was like
here's this one note we want you to be
just be that one note I get what you're
saying like they do hear her one note to
play with but at the same time I didn't
think she took it and was like this is
the one note ah you know like I thought
she at least made it believable to me
like it was at least there was some
subtlety to it you know I didn't buy it
I just thought it was a corny
performance I know it's a family film
but you know that you can make a good
family film with believable performances
and believable characters maybe the
writing was OneNote
but she could have brought more depth to
it you gotta understand like Mila Kunis
great actress Rachel Weisz great actress
and I'm watching this epic film for a
prequel that's very anticipated and it's
like how come these great actors they're
not bringing up depth to these
Lawrence's all right I'm gonna I'm I'm
gonna leave your clubhouse I'm in this
Clubhouse yeah comes to Rachel Weisz
sure let's hear it well I I think that
you know okay you know they it is a
one-note to play character it's kind of
hard there's kind of a spoiler I'm not
gonna say any spoilers but I'm just
gonna say that she's got a motivation
you know and she but it's just like you
know her character is that all the time
and I think that I would do you mean
that in terms of the actual book are you
talking in terms of this like okay you
know she has to play it that way there's
not really a whole lot of other ways to
do it and I mean I think that a lot of
the folks you're looking at is actually
more of a Fault in the writing than in
like the way she's acting because
there's not a lot of ways you can play
that character without playing that
character I see I disagree I think you I
think that the performance was typical
it's like we've seen that type of
performance or about billion other
actors before I mean we only check in on
her so often like she's not she doesn't
get the lion's share of the screen time
like we chicken her off when she's doing
that thing she's working on you know
it's like and that's what we see so I
mean I thought she was subtle enough but
it wasn't it was never interesting to me
that was a thing I never found it
interesting
there was a tip I found her it was a
typical performance I thought all three
witches were very under written so they
couldn't so none of the actor even
Michelle Williams all them were under
written so you couldn't provide any
depth for any of them and I granted with
Rachel why she's the least of all the
witches that needs to death I will give
you that she's a lose because of her
character but still like all three
wishes were just like one note
throughout his split decision number
three writing and directing my biggest
issue with this film was I found all the
characters to be pretty two-dimensional
like all one note you know James Franco
had the most layers but even his
character has a you know an arc that we
want to see him go through but by the
time you reach that mark it was like he
still seems kind of like the same guy
with a little bit more to it
but he doesn't evolve his this films
called oz the great and the powerful
that's a pretty bold title and the film
is not great and it's not powerful and
I'm not saying it has to be that but I
wouldn't even consider this film really
good well first of all the film they're
not saying the film is great and
powerful they're saying Oz is great but
Baz is not great and powerful but we
went there and it was beautiful the Land
of Oz is beautiful but I'm talking about
the character Oz oh shoot the character
okay yeah but like I said earlier like
the witches I found to be very much
under it and you don't really get to
know anyone in the Land of Oz so you
don't really care too much about these
people and James Franco's motivation to
help out these people was like I know
it's kind of funny that it's all pretty
much bent on greed and it's like oh yeah
you know it starts off with greed but
you know where it's gonna go where he
eventually wants to do it for the people
but that's like an first hour of the
film where he's going this adventure but
there's no real sense of danger or
threat because I don't really care about
any of these people I did I mean the
other thing too is that you're kind of
put into a corner because in the
original Wizard of Oz the whole the
whole thing is they pull back the
curtain and he's not that great you know
and so I feel like they they held true
to that idea where he he does become
great but in a way where he's still
largely who he is and so I couldn't
knock it for that like I thought it
worked especially in that universe you
know with what we know about The Wizard
of Oz and stuff like that since it is a
prequel but there's still no real sense
of danger or any real threat and never
got me excited and never got my heart
pumping I was never like oh my god this
is thrilling it was just I was calm
throughout like very calm
well one of the things I liked about the
writing I guess if the I'm not sure if
this is like qualify system but you know
it was it's kind of neat to like watch
the movie and see all the little tie-ins
that they did win yeah that was in 1930
you know cuz they they they did build a
lot of it up and they you did kind of
see like oh this is how you know it
ended up like this way in the 1930
movie this is how that ended up like
that and you know there's a lot of
little things like that and there's
little little throw backs to the book
you know like the the China girl and
there's little maps and stuff that are
all in the books and I was just like
this book stuff but like the list yeah
oh that's that's you know that's that's
kind of all I want to give it because
the first hour of the film is really
kind of slow yeah actually build up to
like where they want to go until you
know a lot later than they really should
the thing about the running in this
movie is that yeah like I do agree that
certain things could have been treated
with more depth but if you think about
the original Wizard of Oz who do we get
to know we get to know Dorothy the Lion
the Tin Man the Scarecrow
and sort of the witch hmm so I mean it's
the same that they have run-ins with the
characters from all has you know you run
into the munchkins you run into these
various people but it's about the main
characters in the Land of Oz so I'm not
hyper upset that the the tinker's and
the munchkins and the palace guards and
so like all those characters weren't
fleshed you know like I said I think
that the Mila Kunis character could have
used some more fleshing and they could
have gone to town more so with James
Franco but I thought they fleshed what
they needed to it's not a fantastic
script but I mean it's there's his my
prompt it's a fantasy adventure that
they talk about scary witches and
there's a big threat at hand that this
witch is gonna buck up Oz but you know
what I find when I never I never felt
worried I never felt concerned for
anybody I never felt that there was
danger at all one of the guys was tied
up like this is she's gonna die oh yeah
okay look there's a good finale there's
a really good finale in this film that's
the only time when I thought it was
really thrilling how's the finale but
there's like two hours before the finale
that is moves at a weird pace and
there's nothing intense about it and
there's nothing thrilling about it I
disagree not saying it's fun at times
but I honestly I was bored sometimes I
never got bored oh I did I I felt like
the invested way more into visual
effects than they did into actual
storytelling they do but they're still
story telling like there is still a
story going on
not as complex as it could be no but I
don't like watching the movie where it's
like wow there's a lot of potential but
they're not meeting in well I I I mean I
think I mean if you look at the original
Wizard of Oz movie you know you you do
know that you know both witches are
still alive well one of them one of them
dies but like I mean at the beginning of
Wizard of Oz you know there's there's
two widgets like allegedly and then like
one of them dies so it's just like you
you kind of know that you know okay you
know at the end of this movie two
witches are both gonna be alive and
there's gonna be a wizard you know so I
kind of like knew the outcome just
because I had seen the old movie you
know I was just like okay so I I just
watched the movie for like the little um
you know the Easter eggs you know that I
liked and just like little things that
they they put together to try and make
like old old oz be the odds that you
know we saw the in the first movie so I
was just kind of keeping my eye out for
that and I wasn't really keeping my eye
out for surprises you know story wise
just because I kind of know but like I
didn't watch it for that I watched it
for like okay how did uh Oz here become
Oz there and I was just kind of keeping
my eye out for little things that they
they might have done that's what I mean
that's what the movie is about that's
what I mean by how the finale is the
most interesting part of the film
because of course by then you finally
see like how Oz got behind the curtain
yeah but before that is where my biggest
issues lie like every it was the finale
I really enjoyed and but everything
before that was kind of just okay to me
I don't hate this film
I don't even though it's coming across
like I do I don't hate it it's like if I
saw it on television or if I even rented
it I probably would have said yeah it's
a good film but the fact that I saw it
in the end of feeders and with all the
hype behind it and the fact that it's a
pretty cool - one of the greatest movies
of all time it's a it's a letdown to me
here's the last thing I have to say
about it is that this movie is clearly
targeted towards family and kids and
which it should be yeah as it should be
and as in terms of that department I
could totally see how a family would
love it and I can see how kids will love
it so you know I got all my complaints
aside that's probably the most important
thing so if you want to go watch it with
your family or if you feel like a kid at
heart still or
thank you I've got a kid watching this
mature review okay what I will say is
this my defense is I've been up a little
bit just because I came up I came in
here with you know issues prepared to
talk about so I want to get my points
made yeah I have issues but what I will
say is this is I like it more than I did
yesterday so it has grown on me since
I've seen it and from talking with you
guys like there are points you guys have
brought up that I actually like yeah you
know you yes shed more light on the film
for me and I think it's because the fact
that it's a prequel wizard of the oz my
expectations are a little bit higher
than it should have been I mean it's a
sorry it would be nice that's that's the
thing about movies of this kind is that
they are almost hard to go into on
completely neutral because it's you have
like the fact that it's the prequel to a
classic and you have the fact that it's
adapted from books and then you have the
fact that you know it's a family movie
but then you also have the fact that
it's a big studio extravaganza so like
there are lots of just peripheral things
to think about I think that's why it's
hard for me to just accept this film on
its own merits as a fun whimsical a
fantasy film and not with more depth I
think that's why I'm having trouble just
accepting it like with what it is
currently and not being more alright
guys thanks for checking out our video
go ahead and tell us below your reasons
to see or not to see oz the great and
the powerful and if you want to check
out my straight to-the-point review a
positive rating the powerful go ahead
and click on the link right here and if
you'd like to see more episodes of
reasons to see more movie reviews click
this button right here and if you want
to get notified every time a new review
is out which will probably be every
weekend go ahead and subscribe scribe
clicking on Rachael right there yeah a
little bit I don't know I don't know if
I want people who click on me
well you're not there when they're click
dude I mean oh she is she is there let's
not ruin them they don't want people to
peer behind the car my gosh the video is
almost writing out you know we're gonna
die
are you okay yeah yeah I've been
breaking before I feel like I should
have picked that one up I'm sorry did
you pick that up I didn't know why I
didn't pick it up and like play with
that side of what happened yeah
hey Ryan I don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on right now
you